Earlier this week I did a story about the
stock market and specifically I pointed out
to you using data that um, Donald Trump and
Trumpists have been hanging their hats on.
Donald Trump's stock market performance as
a sign of Trump winning and being good for
the country, and that there are two major
problems with that.
Number one is that the stock market climbing
is only good for some people, and when stocks
go up and wages stay the same, that's part
of the problem.
That's how wealth continues to accumulate
at the top.
The bigger problem though is that stocks Rose
more under Barack Obama than under Donald
Trump.
I showed this graph when we did the story.
Uh, stocks went up nearly 59% during Barack
Obama's first years in the S and P 500 only
up 46% during Donald Trump's first three years.
Stock's rising roughly 28% more during Barack
Obama's first three years.
Then during Donald Trump's first three years.
Now, when I did the story, I knew there would
be some Trump is to simply wouldn't understand.
They simply wouldn't understand the numbers,
but the degree to which their ignorance has
been weaponized into online trolling and harassment
and cognitive dissonance with the goal of
simply continuing to blindly support Donald
Trump, it even stunned me.
And I'm going to show you some of the YouTube
comments in response to that story.
And the truth is, I could do this with a lot
of stories that we do.
Just pick YouTube comments and show them to
you.
The reason I'm choosing this one is that the
subject matter is so simple and it's very
objective.
It's not super open to interpretation.
If you want to talk about Donald Trump's,
uh, foreign policy maneuvering, what to one
person seems like a blunder could be some
kind of four D chess to someone else.
And there's really like a debate to be had
about it.
This is just super clear.
The S and P 500 climbed 59% during Obama's
first three years and 46% during Trump's.
That means the S and P 500.
The broadest of the big three stock market
indices climbed 25 roughly percent more under
Obama than under Trump.
It's cut and dry.
It's simple.
Check out these comments.
We have examples of basically every type of
response we imagined.
Quote, when you crash it first, it's easy
to increase it.
LOL.
This is funny.
Of course this is nonsense on two fronts.
Most importantly, that stocks didn't crash
under Barack Obama.
That's just made up.
It's not true.
Next comment, quote, I mean a trillion dollar
stimulus package, a government bailout of
the auto industry and near zero interest rates
will do that.
The question is will there be consequences
and will you blame Trump for them?
So this one is similar, but it's from someone
with like a few more arrows in their quiver
saying that Obama effectively bought himself
an inflated market with government spending.
That is an admission that government stimulus
works.
First of all, and hilariously they seem to
be saying that now that Trump has no longer
done the same thing as Obama, we are now seeing
the consequences which appear to be slightly
slower stock growth under Donald Trump.
Completely incoherent.
If it doesn't make sense to you, it's because
it doesn't make sense.
Uh, another comment.
Yeah, but a recovery after a crash will rebound
faster and more easily.
I don't think that's disputable.
Again, I specifically mentioned this one yesterday.
It's a fallacy.
It's a post facto rationalization.
I knew we would get this comment and we did
another comment quote, the stock market went
up because of all that quantitative easing
money from the fed and very low interest rates
under Obama.
If Trump had quantitative easing and near
zero interest rates under his first three
years, it would go up much higher than what
it has.
The stock market is not a good indicator of
a good economy.
This one's funny for a few reasons.
It against sites.
Some of these normal Obama rigged the stock
market to go up with his programs, but then
it also says Trump hasn't gotten any fed benefit.
Even though Trump has Trump's gotten rate
cuts, he complained they weren't big enough.
That's a whole farce, but then they also say
the stock market doesn't matter anyway in
terms of evaluating the economy.
Yeah.
I said that yesterday and yet still the metric
that Trump and his followers choose to use
is stock market performance.
Another comment, quote wrong, Trump had multiple
record high peaks, higher than any point during
Obama.
You are being a disingenuous Democrat.
Also, the market is in the average person's
benefit when we have a market where companies
are struggling to find workers like now versus
workers struggling to find work like under
Obama, this was just incoherent and it's also
laced with ad homonyms.
So not a surprise.
And then lastly, quote, what the hell have
you been smoking?
The market is up 11,000 points since Trump
was elected and 401k are up from 40 to 70%
this one's just a total non-sequitur.
The market is up 11,000 points at which market,
I assume they mean the Dow.
Of course we're talking about the S and P
500 and of course we're talking about the
percentage increase or decrease.
That's what matters.
And whatever happened in anyone's individual
401k is really not relevant to the broader
conversation that we're having.
So the conclusion from this, we can't reason
with these people.
It's impossible.
I want to you to see these comments, to realize
that even on something this simple, they can't
be reached.
You can't reason with them.
You're not going to convince that person to
say, you know what?
You're right.
Let me vote for someone other than Trump in
November of 2020 they will not be part of
our removing Donald Trump.
They will not be part of us accomplishing
anything if anything is going to be accomplished.
So the the revelation needs to be, and I hope
many of you have had it long ago, we need
to go around them and just do everything we
can to prevent them from interfering.
We're not going to convince them to come to
our side.
Let's convince people already on our side
to get out and vote in November of 2020 because
these people are not going to see the light
period